all right guys Jerry here from Geek
contraction today we'll be checking out
Diablo 4 on the Rog Ally my colleague
Zinio has done really extensive
comparisons between the RG Ally and the
steam deck itself today we'll be playing
the most hyped game of the season on the
Rog Airline now the Rog Ally really do
very well with Diablo 4 we're not going
to beat around the bush let's get into
it okay so now guys everyone we're going
to be tackling a stronghold and we can
see all the data here 100 and this is
unplugged as well in small there's a
small little USB charging right at the
top but we're going to go into this and
see how it actually works out and
hopefully don't die I bring her car
repair really hard call over the weekend
together with a lot of my friends zakias
all over the camera he died many times I
didn't but he is his first Diablo but
that's how it is we're going to figure
this out and see how it goes you can see
that there's a lot of action happening
on screen e there's no lag at all which
is really pretty good honestly looking
at how it's going I'm going to be very
very slow as you approach this of course
I don't want to lose my character after
all
um depth is permanent in Hong Kong as
you guys don't know and it's looking
actually pretty good at least I'm doing
this WOW trying this in hardcore we love
to live Dangerously in uh the culture
here performance is actually looking
good battery's at 100 24 Watts
is we can use a hundred percent right
now 24 watts and the temperature is 65
degrees Celsius very manageable and if I
look in the screen here and we have put
our refresh rate
220 Hertz FPS but we're getting about 33
FPS here so what do you guys think does
it look good or not I think it looks
pretty awesome
um
pretty good for games on the bus if you
need to travel it's a bit that's the
tricky part here many people do not know
how they actually use the rji light it
doesn't make sense if you're going to
use this and
as a desktop replacement but you really
want to use it as a as you're going on a
commute or whatnot that way I think that
is the real strength of how the Rog Ally
really does oh you've got a friend here
this is plate live guys this is not
um this is not any uh
any I would say
rehearse or anything I'm playing this
live right now oh what is a Neko do a
deck of explosion Wing didn't really you
see when he did all the console version
and we didn't see any slowdown lag is
the thing that really kills you in
Diablo here I think any anyone will know
and this is where we will see this if it
performs in a very stable 30 30
FPS that we're seeing one question that
most people will be wondering is how do
we even get this up to 60 FPS let's go
into the menus and see if we can even
tweak it accordingly I think we can even
push this even more if we lower down to
the resolution to 720p at 15 watt
performance
oh my God FPS just jumped guys
handheld mode
15 watts and the MPS cells went up let's
get into a into combat and see how this
actually goes off
good enough battle here we'll see how it
goes
yeah how come the guy has three suffixes
I thought this is more level
my HP I think this is the optimized
route we're testing this blind we had no
idea we gave this a shot to see how it
actually would work out and wow color
has impress Asus one thing I think that
many people wouldn't don't realize right
this is mostly like a PC itself
so the UI itself can be actually quite
cramped I noticed that we're not looking
at my abilities right guys look at this
how the hell are you supposed to find
your abilities just like this this is
insane to me I think it's a good
opportunity for blizzard himself to
actually find a work to work together
with rgli to create maybe a specific UI
for this possibly I cannot even run this
down but you guys can see for yourself
and do some extrapolation to see if the
battery life actually makes sense for
you in the first place the tricky part
here is figuring out if
if this is enough time for you to even
run do on your own commutes uh 81 since
we went into the dungeon itself it was
about 84 and remember as you go in the
dungeon 207 pm
this is on performance mode guys this is
not anything unless that you can expect
from the RG it is performing really well
so what you have here for the Rog and I
if you guys have not seen any other
videos it runs on normal USB here and
all you have to do is find a partner
which is a big plug and this is Wyatt
very much like your Game Gear era
experience but let's say if you're
traveling and you're in a hotel room
it's quiet already and you want to go
home and done for the day already
carrying something like this is actually
pretty good to play in at night before
you go to bed
okay
this is the emptiest dankest dungeon
ever
okay shutter strike go in
okay you can see that the FPS is not
impressively any different from the last
time we saw just that most probably the
numbers weren't really updated all right
now they have cleared all the mobs we
have a bit of a breather let's change
out the resolution to 720p and see if we
get even more FPS out of it keeping the
refresh rate at 120. lower the
resolution get more uh frames that is
the ideal here oh okay frames are going
up to 70 FPS not too bad
pretty good
66 FPS I think still very much playable
are you seeing any graphical difference
no for me as long as everything is
readable I think that's the most
important thing when it comes to Diablo
especially if you're playing it on on a
handheld like this
sure
it would be more oppressive you could
see it in more higher Fidelity better
graphics but come on guys it's a small
screen what are you expecting all right
so we run through a dungeon and we have
given a good run of the actual specs
itself doing it handheld and also on
power in doctin mode in some ways maybe
we need to really bring in the big boys
I have the XG mobile here we're going to
see how Diago performs on a 3080 device
it's going to be plugged in we can see
how the FPS works out at the same time
this channel is supported by a lot of
friends like yourself to help us improve
our videos so let's hear from today's
sponsor you're looking for a laptop that
has more power and portability look no
further than the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
it features a large 70 watt hour battery
and stunning Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8 K
120 hertz OLED foldable display powered
by the latest 13 gen Intel Core I9 CPU
and RTX 3050 GPU all packed in a thin
16.9 mm chassis that only weighs 1.5
kilograms so you can stay focused at
work or play for more information check
out asus.com
oh okay we want to shoot a lot of stuff
but
something's happening with the Ally
right now and it goes in the Bios he
tells me to unplug and plug into the
wing I think right now because the Rog
airline has pretty much a lot of layers
and features over each other right now
it's not like true through full-fledged
console handheld nor is it a PC desktop
puzzle and in in order for it to work
well operation wise
there's a lot of consideration I think
maybe it does not run as fast or as
Snappy as someone would like patience is
maybe something that is required his
Diablo Diablo broke this game okay what
I have here right now you can hear the
fans is pouring out really loudly it's
the RG HD mobile with a 3080 plugged
into the RG Asus Li as well
I'm a bit distracted by fan but you can
see FPS now is flying guys 120 FPS on
the screen not sure if you guys can see
but trust me I've got this looking
inside things itself I realized that we
did a little boo-boo earlier FPS limiter
was actually on but you can see all the
refresh rates to give you guys a good
understanding of these settings and we
are now at turbo operating mode as well
so loading screen 180 are we going up
yes oh no look at that no oh no but yeah
foreign
is it smoother do you guys tell me how
it actually looks like through this
camera out here I can't tell but to me I
think it's actually looking pretty good
let's get into a dungeon and see if we
can find something
very good
I I noticed that the controls a lot more
smoother as before so get out there and
come on my rogie step is heavy okay you
can see that when I was even panicking
right and pressing all my my buttons
itself no concern no FPS drop so really
the only problem uh with this game is
really the player
skill issue guys
honestly no impact here FPS is a stable
120 compared to what we had for earlier
handheld it was like going in between
the two
this is pretty good now we're going to
the options what I really want to point
out is how loud those fans are on the XG
mobile I'm about what 60 cm away from
the XV mount it is very Audible and this
is because we are putting this out at 4K
this is the settings here that we have
on the big screen it works I think this
TV is not really optimized for gaming
itself but for the most part you can see
the mouse is uh not great wouldn't run
really want to run anything uh call on
this but we'll give you a shot okay what
we have here is a very quick makeshift
setup of how we actually all looks like
once we have it plugged to the XG mobile
and to the big screen as well this
camera here I don't know
um RG Li
G Mobile our recording with MSI in here
and with your Elgato Nikon or good
friend here this is 4K if you go into
the settings in a bit and you check that
out now that we're back into the game
itself
let's go to the dungeon and give it a
run as well we can see that the
monitoring up there FPS is I think it's
struggling a bit take it
37 FPS not the fastest I would say I
think it's really a situation of more
thinking that how they could even pull
this off but whether or not they even
should have done it okay we're running
through the dungeon right now I can see
it's quite visible in terms of the frame
rate drops uh it is definitely better on
just the mobile itself I think we can
all agree on that
okay now that I've gone through this
quite a bit already and me squatting
here getting really awkward
is that the frame rates aren't that
ideal here possibly it could be because
we're running through your Elgato as
well there's quite a bit of recording
and there might be a bit of bottlenecks
but for the most part this might be a
bit scary when you're looking to use
this as a desktop solution most of the
settings are set pretty much on the Ally
itself and if you look at this we do
need to actually go into our settings
and maybe we bring down the resolution
you'll look weird on this but it might
improve the performance let's go to 1080
which is a native resolution keep the
changes suddenly it feels a bit more
smoother I realized I had to do these
settings earlier on let's put it into
Diablo once again and you guys tell us
what do you think of the performance
difference I don't think it's optimal in
any way but for the sake of science let
me check it out
so the conditions really need to be
right to get all this all together it's
a real experiment to disease oh wow we
have 120 FPS right now at the top this
is on 1080p if you're playing it from
distance we look at the options here
yeah
feel the power okay I wasn't very
confident of using
[Music]
um
most controllers on most things what
they eat some lag wow
if you don't mind playing at 1080p I
think this gives the best performance
120 FPS
but yeah that's what you guys think this
is one of the modes that we have right
now Airline connected to the XG mobile
and we have fitted on a4k TV
that's pretty much all the pieces that I
want to put this through it's a bit of a
tricky Prospect to actually get Diablo
working on the Rog Ally but for the most
part it actually works when you play
hard coin I'm not quite sure but let me
give you my final thoughts after this
all right that is Diablo 4 on the Rog
Ally and I honestly think it has
improved and done really well and
performed really impressively since I
last checked it out when it was in the
review phase updated quite a bit and I
think if you can put the conditions just
right thinking about performance mode 15
watts on 720p resolution you don't
really see anything being really
affected I'm getting good FPS we are
seeing about 60
50 FPS very good for us we possibly even
run Nightmare dungeons if you think of
any other game that you want to see us
check out on the RG Ally let us know in
the comment section below and if this
video was helpful to you remember to
like And subscribe it really does go a
long way